Trainz many action stars in real life is
that right I have Tobey Maguire and
James Franco for spider-man Brad Pitt
for Troy I did the stunts for Donatello
and Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles two and
three
you were Donatello and I love your
mullet that's fantastic I thought it'd
be good to take you through some drills
that an action hero would normally go
through preparing for hero drills when
you were done with me tonight I will be
action hero caliber I mean the first
drill in kungfu terms is called wearing
your iron shirt and having a steel pair
of pants on okay don't know what that
means okay I'll tell you so basically
it's very simple this is the drill
that's not only going to give you like a
very strong upper body but that will
also make you tough mentally because
there's a lot of pain that you're gonna
have to endure throughout this process
but it's okay so it's it's very simple
you take this part if you want you just
have to stand here and I'm gonna hit and
kick you now in an advanced situation I
would use my bare fists but in this case
I'm going to use my leather paddle
because it's not gonna
okay oh that's really stings try not to
let anyone see that it's hurting you and
that's part of this pretty good yeah
that's great
so we can take turns going back and
forth with each other or I could just do
it to you and you could shut up
[Applause]
I'm gonna get you into character okay
now because of your pumpkin ish
complexion and hair I thought that the
most fitting superhero for you to be
would be Michelangelo the Ninja Turtles
okay we have a Michelangelo mask for you
[Applause]
my whole body is one big wound right now
look at the ass
let's work on your intensity intensity
okay we have that superhero persona that
look okay so get into it okay here
meanest toughest badass look right now
[Applause]
maybe a little less constipated looking
you know okay this is noxious
okay that's good I feel we're taking it
to the next level okay
okay we do now so now next up you have
your intensity yes I want you to work on
how your voice is broke okay I want to
work on your on your hero pose okay and
your grace hero pose what's that up with
you great cuz I have noticed that you
have a balla deck type of you know a
very Sensibility athletic and sinewy
body my movements are fluid so we'll
we'll capitalize on that but maybe add a
little masculinity to it and just bounce
around thick Mohammed Ali Mohammed Olli
oh yeah okay not okay not so alien like
more human being like
more like a human being there you go all
the way around and then strike the pose
that's actually pretty good
you're gonna dance around and when I say
stop you stop in your hero pose okay
pose super intense okay around and
circle nice and loose nice and loose
nice and loose nice and loose there we
go and stop good and again circle circle
nice and loose nice and loose
and stop okay now Yoshio is going to
attack you yeah okay you have to defend
yourself I know what to do when he comes
in just come in with multiple punches
punch him and then flip him somehow
whatever you'd like to do okay okay here
we go good love the training I love the
training on that start on time just told
me nothing okay
[Applause]
[Music]